We are now going to bring in
Colonel Cedric Leighton.
You have been watching this
since the beginning.
You have been talking about this
The invasion happened,
I think on the 24th.
I ended up on Poland on the 26th, as
thousands of refugees
were coming over the border from
from Ukraine.
I'm curious
what your thoughts are on hearing
the President of the United States
in a country
that is currently in war
with sirens going off there are no U.S.
troops there.
And yet he says
we are going to stick with you
for the long haul.
In other words,
you have our full support.
What does that mean to Ukraine?
What does that say to Russia
and the rest of the world?
Well, Sarah, good morning.
This is a really big deal.
And the way that the president
has orchestrated this
this would kind of be like
if Roosevelt
had visited London during the blitz in
World War Two.
This is that significant.
So what we're seeing here
is really
a transformation of the world order.
The Russians,
by their invasion of Ukraine,
have tried to go in
and they've tried to upend
the world order.
The they and the Chinese
are very much interested
in making sure that the United States
is not the dominant power in the world.
And by doing this invasion of Ukraine,
you know, almost a year ago today,
you see that
there is so many different
aspects to this.
You had the initial attack on Kiev
the one that was repulsed.
We all remember that
40 mile long
column of tanks
that was into armored personnel
carriers and trucks
that was supposed to make it to Kiev.
They never made it to Kiev.
And the very fact
that the president of the United States
a year
on, can say
two presidents, Alinsky on presidents.
Alinsky's home turf
that we are standing by you,
that we're standing with you.
That is incredibly significant
because what it shows is
that there are so many different things
so you look at, for example, the tanks
that all the allies have pledged.
You know,
you've got 31
tanks from the United States, the Abrams
tanks, the Germans
with their leopard tubes,
and the Canadians as well,
and the Brits
bringing their challengers in.
That's just symptomatic of
what's really going on here.
Those tanks can make a big difference
on the battlefield,
because what we want
the Ukrainians to do
is engage in a war of maneuver.
Right now, there is a bit of a
you know,
some people would call it a stalemate,
but basically the forces are stalled,
especially in the east.
And if they can break out of that,
it would be kind of like
what happened in World War One,
where the United States came in
the tanks were invented.
And that
really increased mobility
on the very static front
on the Western front in that war.
And this same kind of philosophy is what
the military part of
this is going to be like.
And, you know, seeing these pictures
coming out of Kiev,
that not only underlines
the military dimension of this,
but it also underlines
the geopolitical part of this,
which is very significant because
because the United States
is not going to go quietly
as the dominant power of the world.
And we're saying to the Russians
and to anybody else who's watching
that we are
not only sticking with Ukraine,
but we're going to do this
for as the president
said, as long as it takes.
I think the next question, Colonel, is
what else will come to get the job done
for Ukraine. Right.
And the fact that Russia is tapped
almost all of its ground forces.
But as our reporting show
still has
a significant air power reserve
that it hasn't tapped.
Can this be won by Ukraine?
Without us F-16s?
Well, the bottom line, Poppy, on
that is probably no.
And the reason I say
that is in modern warfare,
the air superiority has been key
to the success of land forces.
And it's also been key
to providing that a cover
for the military's
actions of whatever domain they're using.
So what's remarkable
is that the Russians
haven't achieved
air superiority at all in anything
that they've done here.
And when you see the, you know,
the possibility of an F-16
coming in there with,
you know, its ability to
not only hit ground targets
but hit air to air targets,
that becomes a significant element
of an air campaign.
The problem that we have
is bringing
all these forces together
and making sure that the Ukrainians
have the training
that they need
in order to effectively
use this weapon system.
And, of course,
we're seeing them do this.
You know, in Britain,
we have the initial
aspects of training pilots,
Ukrainian pilots.
That's going to be
exceptionally important
to get this right.
And in order for Ukraine to succeed,
I believe that air power is going to be
a significant component to that.
And you made a very interesting
point, Poppy,
because the Russians have not used
a significant portion of their air power.
Probably several reasons
of that for that.
But the very fact that they're not doing
that shows that either
they have it in reserve
or it doesn't work.
And if it doesn't work,
the Russians have
major problems,
even more significant
than what we've seen so far.
Yesterday, U.S.
Senator Lindsey Graham
called on the US
to start training Ukrainian pilots today
on those F-16s.
Thank you very much, Colonel Leighton.
We appreciate it very much.
And for more perspective on this
just absolutely historic visit
that we are now
seeing still underway right now,
I want to bring in David Sanger,
who is CNN's
national security
analyst and national
security correspondent
for The New York Times.
David, obviously,
you and I both covered Biden
and this has been a trip
that he had been wanting to take
for about a year now.
He has not done so so far.
They were talking about security reasons
why he could not go.
I think one
big question, though, is
what do you think
the reaction is like right now?
What's the response
happening inside the Kremlin
as they are
watching President Biden
on the ground with President Zelensky
You know, it's a fascinating question
because
President Putin
is supposed to give a speech tomorrow
that was supposed to be his rationale
for continuing a war
that has already produced about 200,000
Russian casualties,
including we think, 50,000 or more dead.
That was not the plan.
The plan was that, of course, Ukraine,
and he was supposed
to be Russian territory by now.
And so what you're going to see
tomorrow are
two very different visions of
not only where the war could go,
but between President Putin's speech
and then President Biden's
speech, two
very different visions
of how Europe should be organized.
And that's why
this is really such a critical moment
in that
that the end of that post-Cold War order
we've been discussing for so long
And so President Biden
will then come
here to Poland, of course,
where he is supposed to speak tomorrow.
That's going to be a huge aspect of this
as well.
We've talked about the role
that Poland has played, a critical role.
They've had a big change
in just the last year.
But a big question has been
where they've been funneling, of course,
these weapons
and arms
shipments that they have been
getting into Ukraine.
Obviously,
Ukraine wants to see
different levels of that.
And what the White House announced today,
the half a billion dollars in aid package
but a lot of the things
that we've seen them send before,
it obviously did not
include the longer
range missiles
that Ukraine is in wanting
or the F-16 fighter jets.
They've also said that
they believe they so desperately need.
What are you watching
on that front, David?
Well, Caitlin, I
spent the weekend
at the Munich Security Conference,
so we had about 50 members of Congress,
a number of members
of the Cabinet, Secretary of State
Blinken, and, of course,
Vice President Harris, who gave a speech
calling, I think was was good evidence
that the Russians have conducted
not only war crimes,
but are crimes against humanity.
But that leaves open the question
of how far President Biden
is ready to go to expand their support,
because while he says
we're there as long as it takes,
he doesn't say what we're there with.
And the complaint that we heard here
from the Ukrainians
who were
at the conference in large numbers
was that they simply don't
have what they need
to sustain over the long term.
And there is, in fact,
some tension
inside the White House
and inside the administration
about whether you give them
what they need for the next few months
or you give them what they need
to make it
impossible for Russia
to try something like this again.
And those may be very different things.
And, of course, President Biden
increasingly concerned that weapons
that can reach deep inside
Russia could provoke a much wider war or
nuclear use.